[Music]
and good parenting news submitted by
lizbo a viral video shows a father
punishing his 10 year old boy by making
him run in the rain that makes sense and
that's what my father should have done
for me I would have been skinny
you [ __ ] animal hugged a father
running in the rain is bad wait in the
rain from I want to be playing outside
in the rain I was like when it rains
like I can't wait I got my rain boom
puddles yeah I would jump off puddles
and [ __ ] no like in northern Minnesota
then maybe it's means it's me oh but
where is this Virginia oh come on I
lived in Virginia it rains nice down
yeah the rain squall can be cold but
these kids fact that it's really bad
good athletic who the [ __ ] cares dude
when I was a kid I used to train them
all the time I'm definitely a clip that
was a punishment that's what people
outraged helps his back if he falls yeah
keeps it off the ground I don't know
like and it's and it's better to have
your kid [ __ ] eat 22 Twinkies and
[ __ ] name all decent [ __ ] I think like
what yeah where's your priorities cuz if
my dad said hey you have two choices
you're either gonna run in the rain or
I'm gonna [ __ ] you up I'm gonna run in
the [ __ ] rain Plus like getting beat
by a bamboo stick son yeah alright dad's
name was Brian Brian the hero he was on
Facebook live and he was filming his son
running to school and he was just
talking over there so he was going about
6 miles an hour behind a son my son has
finally got in trouble on the bus enough
to where he got actually kicked off the
bus for 3 days because he was being a
little bully which I do not tolerate
cannot stand
and therefore he has to now run the
school don't we write about one mile
from the school so all that bad
he's got the experience of running the
school ironically since he's been
running the school this week his
behavior hasn't got in trouble at school
this week or last week he was just
absolutely out of his mind
this right here is old school simple
parenting this ain't killing nobody this
is a healthy way mr. Chung did not agree
because it's you know exercise if you
say we need gun control people you know
here you go this is what we need
parenting true huh very simple thing I
like you've got love guns and everything
else but I love my children more
anything in this world so I'm gonna take
initiative to raise them I can't walk
into my safe like I can guns you know I
can control guns easily forever this
I've got to make sure I control now so
it was I thought it was pouring [ __ ]
rain yeah what's the problem
I love this guy why does a mile at that
point there were mile from the school
how many miles is a school from his home
even if I took it from this point at the
bottom I don't know you know what this
is a kid [ __ ] running like his dad's
chasing him with the car - there's
definitely fear - that jog - a lot he
hasn't even looked back he's like don't
look back this is actually really great
because um ADHD affects young boys for
sure more than more than girls by it by
far right and a lot of a lot of boys
have trouble focusing in class because
they have so much energy I wish I had
something like this I walked to school
but then it wasn't enough cuz I was only
like a couple blocks away and I wish I
had something like this where I'm just
like in the morning and then when I'm in
class I could focus in more Zen and
chilled out yeah yeah the family here
what in the [ __ ] is he wearing daddy
looked like he needs to run a little
balancing brand I was like he's wearing
a Mortal Kombat up yeah that's what I
thought
oh okay Halloween I was like what a
[ __ ] weirdo
everybody got candle wax just [ __ ]
melted all its like no one of the kids a
bully yes to dress like that he can't do
he has no choice you gotta wear that
you've got to be a bullet no it looks it
just looks like they're going to the
Medieval Fair so I think he's a ninja it
looks like an inch he's like I don't
know I won't say no ninjas gonna wear
that you'll get you good scene yeah for
sure 100%
ketchup red Victor all right my mother
what the hell is going on is it like
kids who got abused or something from
their parents and when they grow up they
don't want to show any type of tension
to their kids or it's the people that
are just expressing their own inner
insecurities so people that think I
can't do that I would have slipped and
fell
I can't run a mile that backpack is will
break my back like there's kids in
cross-country running 10 miles every
single day so those kids and they're
running in the rain it's controlled by
the school I've just halluf it kids out
there but it's just people that are
ignorant to that because it's their own
and secure that I like wait this is
punishment because there was this guy at
high school named Billy very very large
large Asian guy better than me at the
time he used to run on the track with
his [ __ ] backpack filled with books
and he was perfectly fine yeah so if
that [ __ ] 300-pound agent who could
do it then I'm pretty sure you this
kid's gonna be okay too but there are
there's a contingent of parents out
there who I think don't believe in
instilling fear and their children at
all and I and I don't think there's been
any better teacher to me than fear oh
yeah you know I mean where it's like if
I do this this will happen to me like if
I do this I will be punished this way
like it's like a one-to-one ratio like
oh if I if that happens then I know
that's just like there's consequences in
the choices that you made right but then
there are parents out there who just
want to be seen as a beacon of all
positivity well those are the parents
that we have to beat up so I agree bully
those parents and beat them oh yeah yeah
and it was cute because his
eight-year-old sister wanted to run to
so them nice cute they could run
together
yeah the dad later posted another video
showing himself running with both both
of his kids cuz that's for sure was like
I wanted to try too
beat my brother that's cool like his
guys getting exercise too cuz he look
really out of shape telegin yeah and he
said that he shared the video for a
laugh and he said be there for your kids
parent them yeah well he said if you got
your pennies in a water we're watching a
kid jog I feel sorry for you I really
don't care kids are [ __ ] unhealthy
obese entitled I want to hear what these
people said do we have any of that uh
what I said earlier I don't have the
actual comments nor did he post this on
a Facebook's and it got shared a lot and
then people are like commenting oh they
could slip and fall that's a danger
[ __ ]
no but it's it's fine let them exist
because you know you're gonna have kids
that are gonna do better and then it's
just less competition yeah ice cream no
they're just saying that you could get
sick oh you get sick or in school than
running in the rainbow in school high
five and your friends and [ __ ] like it's
not knows a little [ __ ] yeah this
stuff that used to have us do two words
like everybody hold hands get the person
next to you it's like that's getting you
sicker than sure that any [ __ ] go
away and then jeromy's I'd rather do the
hell week Marine Corps thing like you're
sitting in the water and like water
splashing over your [ __ ] head you got
a bunch of gear on
I think I'd get sicker like in a prayer
circle with a bunch of kids and get sick
too cuz their kids bring the [ __ ]
disgusting journal I think always get
sick with that or not us Casey yeah we
always get Kesey sick without fail so we
need to either volatile strong as
jeans are very yeah you have Casey down
that's true you don't even drink water
and you survive how is that possible I
don't even eat this whenever I need to
move I always get myself some strong
Mexicans that are half my size but they
carry twice as much as me and they take
half as much pain oh god you can trust
them
I had a Chinese moving company they took
a [ __ ] break every hour like they had
to smoke a cigarette a drink of beer and
in the Mexican guys they just did like
all the same amount of work but like in
15 minutes when I worked in a high-rise
like shitty job America like underneath
lights like this like the [ __ ]
halogens the [ __ ] was like take smoke
breaks like everybody in that whole
office building smoke because and it
like made new people who didn't smoke
ever before smoke because then you get
to go take your smoke break yeah cuz no
boss is gonna stand in the way of
somebody in their addiction yeah yeah so
like yeah go take your [ __ ] smoke
break no problem oh man I remember
watching people coming in that office
who are like like wow everybody just
gets to go take a smoker because I guess
you should smell good oh so they don't
do it on their 15-minute break no they
just go whatever the [ __ ] Oh 45 minutes
35 minutes whenever when I was working
in the hospital one of the corkers she
would always take smoke break or a
couple of them and my boss said that if
they're gonna be taking their smoke
breaks and they had to take a shorter
lunch so they didn't have like as long
as it lunch cuz they would always go
every like 15 minutes they'd go outside
it's been like if you're cold girls know
their rights they can sue yeah I bet
morale was pretty low there but it's
okay smoking is such a pain in the ass
cuz like it's just you're so highly
addicted you can't function without this
[ __ ] thing I would tell this to a
child smoking is one of the coolest
things you can ever do and you could
ever get caught doing but it's bad for
you it is cool as [ __ ] looking I think I
think for smoking you got to work hard
to get addicted to smoking though it's
not like all the other drugs cuz all the
other drugs you do one hit and you're
like mmm this is Bob right
but the DARE program makes it seem like
you pick up a cigarette and then all
sudden you wake up 14 years later
sucking dicks in an alley right like
literally that's how dare was yeah but
you smoke a cigarette you're like this
is [ __ ] gross but you don't want to
look like that so you keep smoking and
everyone around you is like is cool and
then like before you know what you're
[ __ ] addicted cuz you worked hard to
get that addiction good for you that was
dare to they always had some guy come to
school and he's like hello my name is
Baxter Morgan I started smoking
cigarettes at approximately 13 years old
around the age a lot of you are yeah and
then he's like he's like I was on black
tar heroin within three months of taking
smoking my first cigarette it was like
the worst example I'd sold to be it was
the funny cuz I'm just like that's that
sounds insane like goodness like what if
cigarettes have to do with you sucking
dick bro the old lady that had the
[ __ ] hole and she just [ __ ] hit
that [ __ ] from her I was like whoa my
grandpa had in church war they have a
pastor come in he's like a former
convict and he's like you want to end up
like me I was like dude you're talking
to the wrong people none of these kids
are getting beggars you know what I did
it inspired me it was like oh you know
what I want to get tattoos and join a
gang
so I could [ __ ] one day inspire other
people but that's the prerequisite I
gotta do all the crime first and then I
could be a pastor yeah and it also made
me think as long as I do all the crime
as long as one day there's always one
day I could turn background your name
and people accept me this like sent me
back again a friend of ours did mission
trips in Haiti and so one of the pastor
was a former game game man he had all
these tats and all these like gun wounds
and scars he try to show it to the kids
to scare them about his life if they got
inspired he was a lot of talk to the
youth that he wanted to be like so dough
exactly this type
[Music]
[Music]